so much of this show is about sort of
holiday traditions I'm interested do you
all have any specific holiday traditions
you always do yeah we definitely do
holiday traditions I don't think it's at
the level that the Quinn family
traditions at but um but I I definitely
like I would love to bake cookies that
have been passed down generations what
type of cookies they're like well
there's these candy cane ones there's
these like little like I don't know how
to explain them there's like it's so
good it's like an almond mix in like a
almost like a dumpling mm-hmm um it came
from my great-grandma so it's just like
we literally has been passed down so
that's one of our traditions my mom is
really on the caroling tradition train
she's like this is gonna be our
tradition so yeah well we'll actually do
it we will get the you know the sheets
of music and we'll go door-to-door some
singer so uh I you know my mom is like
come on you can do this but yes I do
this every day I get to be a bit of like
the kid dragging her feet but then it's
always fun it's it's like it's nice to
do something festive and bring the
holiday cheer what's your favorite
caroling song what's your what's your
go-to caroling song let's go to caroling
song I mean I think Santa Claus is
coming to town that one that one kurse
that one happens um and that's very
cheery you know so like when people hear
that it gets the vibe lifted it's so
funny that with like Christmas songs
yeah Eve on set like we know everyone
obviously knows all the Christmas songs
and caroling songs but then you like
find out the real words and you're like
that's what did that says yeah here it
is like so surprised or you like verse
three and you're like no this was in the
songs after figgy pudding like do they
play Christmas songs on set to get you
guys in the mood is that uh we can the
show
yeah we definitely learn oh yeah
Carolee and then there is like yeah
there's something Christmas music within
the show that you had play on set was
that annoying though
was it annoying hearing the same song
over no I think it sets the tone because
it is Christmas morning when it happens
yes so release set the tone of like you
know Don Quinn which is a dentist like
playing the music and trying to wake us
all up and almost be like it's like come
on dad you know so like really helped
with like the scene I think yeah how
much of your characters directions were
you aware of ahead of time when you sort
of sign up this is fairly certain you're
out yeah zero-zero Tucker was really
funny he did not want to share what was
happening with her with our characters
but I think it's really cool and
interesting because he's so specific and
he knows what he wants which I really
appreciate it would Tucker um but like
it makes you realize like I think with
each episode for my character she goes
through a lot of things and faces a lot
of challenges and finding her own
strength you know through the show and
and and who she's becoming and what I
appreciate about not knowing about it
was that there's a journey there that
she has to take and I was taking the
journey with her by not knowing so I was
kind of questioning what my character
was going through as she's questioning
stuff as well so yeah I really
appreciate it yeah I think there is
something to that approach where like if
you don't know what's coming ahead of
your character then you can only be in
the moment as the character and make the
choices that somebody would know if they
only had so much information so yeah
there was there was kind of like a big
will they won't they for my character as
well and I kept asking Tucker I was just
like so what does this mean like what
does that mean and like trying to like
read between the lines but he really
kept didn't really come to like yeah
yeah that's crazy because the characters
going crazy places I was shocked they
will be to everyone you guys have both
have tremendous sitcom experience what
is it like working with a primarily
dramatic actor like Dennis on a show
like this do you really embraced
yeah this went in on it and I really
respect that fearlessness because there
are a lot of differences like coming
from a single camera where it's mostly
about like up close you know small
expression things just sitcoms where
it's a lot about like rhythm and like
interacting with your partner and maybe
like a different kind of way and like
considering the the stage the fourth
wall of it so he was a super fast
learner and he also had such like a
grounded length intake like he was like
he really appreciated that you know we
all came from comedy and really had a
high respect for I mean just like our
director and like listening to what you
know Pam won in and Tucker and like kind
of being around us like he's just such a
good guy like he's an all-around amazing
person